Kim Kardashian admits she and Nicole  Richie used to shoplift together when  they were kids honestly I haven't been  shopping in months  [Music]  the reality stars k'kaw beauty brand may  have earned her upwards of 14 million  dollars in June with the first round of  contour kits I'm so excited about it but  when she was a little girl she was  snatching up makeup with the five finger  discount so sorry to me the 36 year old  recently confessed on her app that she  and her famous pal used to steal  lipstick together it was crazy  quote when Nicole Richie and I were  around 11 we went into a drugstore in  Malibu and took lipstick we thought we  were so bad I mean hello Kim even  remembers the brand quotes I can't  remember the name of the color but it  was a brown shade from Revlon the  entrepreneur chalks up her bad behavior  to not being more of a rebel growing up  so weird  quote I wasn't much of a partier growing  up so this was about as rebellious as I  got perfect  [Music]